[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video we are going
to talk about new major teases regarding
the longest battle in cinema history
that will take place at Winterfell in
the third episode of the final season
we're also going to talk about our
season a thesis as well as about new
promo so let's get right into it
Entertainment Weekly's cover story
Lessman gave us an inside look into the
final game turn season through the eyes
of James Hebert but it seems that report
was not enough for him and so he decided
to reveal even more about his final set
visits for years James Hebert has been
one of the very few journalists HBO has
invited on set and is broken my stories
about things to come in Westeros in case
you're not caught up with the news let's
quickly recap the info we have thus far
a few weeks ago James revealed that
season it will open have interval with
an episode that contains plenty of
callbacks to the show's pilot instead of
King Robert's procession arriving it's
Danny and her army what follows is a
thrilling and tensed intermingling of
characters some of whom have never
previously met many who commenced the
histories as they were prepared to face
the inevitable invasion of the army of
the Dead senses not thrilled with John
banning me to Danny the drama builds to
a confrontation in the army of the Dead
that's expected to be the most sustained
action sequence ever made for television
or film and we also learned that there
are characters in the finale that we do
not expect so basically most of the main
characters will be a Winterfell at the
beginning of season eight with Jaime and
a few more yet to arrive there will be a
drama until the great war starts the
night King comes to Winterfell
Hebert's Entertainment Weekly cover
story about Dmitry on season 8 is the
best resource for fans who simply cannot
wait any longer for April and now
speaking on a new episode of his game of
Thrones weekly podcasts he dropped even
more knowledge Jim Hobart thesis and
intimate spectacular final season of
Game of Thrones let's hit some of the
highlights
starting with Hubert's take on the
battle for Winterfell Oh which seems to
be the greatest battle ever filmed they
spent 10 months filming six episodes of
television which would normally take
about two months that's pretty crazy and
the water that was not a big battle
stuff but the regular scenes of two
people talking holiday he clarifies if
it's a scene that would normally take a
day to shoot they'd spend several days
shooting because they're trying so hard
to get every little thing right so they
do take out their take from all sorts of
different angles so that in editing they
have different ways to piece it together
but the battle is the big sexy thing
Hobart concedes it's shaping up to be
what probably almost certainly is the
longest consecutive
sequence in cinema history they'd love
to try and find other ones out there the
one in the two towers in the Lords of
the Rings which is about 40 minutes and
in the movie 13 assassins which was also
around 40 minutes this is going to be
longer than 40 minutes it's pretty nuts
HBO has also gone all-in on sets for
season 8 building out to the Winterfell
set to make it as close to real Castle
as possible
according to Hibbert the crew was up to
the challenge they massively expanded
the Winterfell set you can wander around
for the camera at any direction and it
shows more Winterfell one of the
directors pointed out that even in a
big-budget Marvel or Star Wars movie
they usually only build what the actors
are gonna stand directly in front of and
fill the rest with green screen but for
this set and a few others as well they
built it as 360 degrees set so you don't
have to fill it with special effects you
don't have to favor one particular angle
you can have cameras follow people
around you can do unusual angles then
come up with different things on the day
of shooting so it allows us a lot more
creativity and it helps the actors no
acting required they're running around
these sets fighting with fake blood on
snow snow flying everywhere torches
burning firing smokes it feels like
right there if I've been following a
mentor on season 8 news and leaked
photos you know that there's a big
battle set to take place in season 8 and
it's now been confirmed to take place in
the third episode of the final season by
the actor who plays the night king
Vladimir verdict verdict led the new
sleep during a fan convention in Hungary
he said and spoiled in the third episode
of the last season there's a battle that
the creator's intended to be historic
moment in television almost the full
episode will be about a battle it will
take about one hour so it won't be until
the third episode that the night horizon
interval why that long you must warn her
that's because the night king will not
star its conquest with Winterfell the
night King will hit last heart and
karhold first just as Jon Snow predicted
after the night king is done with them
he will proceed south arriving at
Winterfell in Episode three the living
we just made a knee as their champions
will be ready
verdict States they filmed this battle
for three months in the wind and the
rain of doors and then for another month
in a huge studio which makes this far
Nevada mostly Britain's the battle
cyclists in the show's history and
therefore in the history of TV I can
tell you that there will be no shortage
of surprises in season 8 for the
continues there will be a lot of dragons
the night king will return and in season
the biggest battle for the throne will
be completed this battle is directed by
me well supposing the guy
and some of the best episodes of gay
materials like hard convinced of winter
and Battle of the bastards it's brutal
said star pair dinklage tyrion lanister
it makes the battle the bastards look
like a theme park writing earlier about
this historic sequence James Hebert
called it wall-to-wall action and
detailed how it jumps between stories of
several different characters what this
means is basically while in the battle
for Winterfell in season six we followed
only stories of a very few characters in
this battle however almost all the main
characters are here and he has to jump
between the stories of all these
different characters we have Jon Snow
with his direwolf fighting on the ground
and then he with her dragons fighting in
the sky we have characters like Arya
Stark the Hound that was bearing Jorah
tormund bring Rayborn ginjury all the
northern Lords also blame Ray J Brown
and Jamie as well fighting on the ground
although the story will most likely
follow our and Jamie while all these
other characters are around them we also
have brain senses Sam Gilly Varys Robin
Iranian Tyrion all of whom might not be
the first line of defense but the story
will definitely follow tyrion and brain
the story will also follow the opposite
side the night king whose story will
without a doubt clash with Dany's while
fighting her in the sky daniel jog on
the night genome is aryan possibly Jon
on a trio named after his father perhaps
what we also know for a fact is that
winter will not fall at Winterfell this
battle will be a huge defeat for the
living the Mist frosted our wolf's
marker over as well as the marker for
Denny's and solid forces but
unfortunately the northern army and the
unsullied are not going to be only
casualties for the living it's confirmed
that most of the track evil fault too
and then shortly after we brought back
to lie by the White Walkers to basically
act as their minions here you can see
the track you whites riding on horseback
one would think that this might be the
White Walkers so I've already been seen
riding horses but during the filming the
White Walkers are just guys in
prosthetics and makeup except for their
blue eyes which are added in
post-production
the green suits like the ones you can
see on this the track however are used
for whites the decayed skeletal kind is
achieved with the help of visual effects
hence the green suits but the clothing
and saddles we can definitely say that
these are the track White's what we
cannot say for a fact although it's
being hinted by the official tease is
that Danny will at some point burn for
more - Reggie loyalists here we can see
the tracking marker being burned
does that foreshadowed Danny burning the
track he that fell during the battle for
Winterfell and became White's you decide
long stir sure the night king will
conquer the north in the living or at
least what's left of them we'll have to
treat south and once again part of it
surfs in urine that said he birds so
much more than grand spectacle there's
been so much focused on the spectacular
ness of the battles but they're not
skimping on the one-on-one scenes and
character scenes I think people are
going to be surprised about how intimate
the final season is in addition to the
spectacular stuff that you're expecting
Heber dentists is the ending without
giving away specifics of course what he
want in any final season is things to be
unexpected but also make sense so you
don't want anything to surprise you for
surprises sake you want everything to
feel earned and to look back and go okay
yeah I could see how they were building
to that and from that I know from the
final season it does that he bird also
discusses the emotional table read which
was thoroughly covered in the original
report though he had speculatively that
it might have been filmed for future
blu-ray extra word alike as well as the
heightened security on set and then
anxiety his secret season 8 knowledge is
causing him a feeling he describes as
carrying around the pop culture nuclear
codes in her head for more funny stories
and some details I might have missed I
recommend you check out the full episode
finally Huberty arises the trailer may
be coming quite soon though I did not
hear on the first day winter as I and
many fans expected or should I say hoped
for now on to the new promo over the
last couple of days HBO has been on a
bit of promotional blitz first releasing
very aware various celebrities sit on
the arm tone and encourage people to
binge the show before the season 8
premiere in April then stars of eternal
sense I'm a civilian sorry I and Kit
Harington Jon Snow are doing the same
thing mentioning quite a few great
reasons to watch a show Dragons why
Walker's Kit Harington sophie Turner
lots of people not that many people
people already familiar with Jim Jones
may be more interested in the fact that
this promo is very likely filmed on the
set of season 8 is there anything we can
get from it to start all three actors
earn the same set with stone pillars in
background which is highly resembling
the Winterfell crypts based on earlier
footage released by HBO we know just
what will return to Winterfell
probably very early in the season there
have also been some reports about scenes
set in the crypts we'll see the crypts
again in the first two episodes of
season 8 at least one of those scenes
will involve characters discussing Nets
death a popular topic whenever people go
down there the production filmed at
least one scene at Shane's castle an
ancient ruin structure that's been used
extensively throughout the series for a
variety of locations that scene
reportedly involved two leading cast
members happens very early in season and
set
the crypts beneath Winterfell in
addition the scene is set to end with
someone blowing a horn which could be
good
signalizing that reinforcements are
coming or could be quite bad signalizing
that White Walkers have reached
Winterfell
are they the one that will be involved
in this scene or are we overthinking and
they all just gathered on this location
to shoot the promo we'll find out in
April
they're here guys new details regarding
the final season of Game of Thrones
especially the battle for Winterfell a
new promo that might not be giving away
much but that's still something let me
know your opinion about all of this in
the comment section down below and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]
[Music]